I think of productivity as a face there  is a a phase in your life where you have  to think about productivity and then  there's other phases where you think  about creativity I see this kind of like  pendulum productivity creativity  productivity creativity and if you go  too far on either end of the spectrum  you start hitting diminishing returns  and you start to get stuck so you can  get so fixated on productivity your work  starts to become formulaic it starts to  become very boring and it's time to kind  of go to the other end of the spectrum  creativity but then you can go to  foreign creativity that's when you get  too precious you get two oh no that's my  art it has to be this certain way and  you know you talk to someone six months  later what are you doing oh I'm working  on my my one painting for the last six  months that also doesn't work you're  getting stuck you're getting locked up  in your own preciousness